Who are you in this vast multiverse
stephen strange your reckoning is long overdue
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer video
there's a bunch of new footage and easter eggs and
references so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel we're doing a giveaway
for imax tickets for the movie all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the video
everybody just getting really hyped up to see
this variant of scarlet witch just go completely
ham on the entire multiverse illuminati like
r.i.p superior iron man r.i.p this variant of
professor x you thought i was asleep didn't you
acting thank you very much for coming back patrick
stewart though and whoever winds up playing this
alternate version of iron man that it seems like
also thanks to some of the newer trailers we have
a much clearer much sharper hd version of this
scene of him in the illuminati's main chamber so
i think we got a much better look at who some of
these members are but one of the coolest things
during this new trailer is seeing scarlet witch
just go completely crazy on this alternate
version of iron man and his version the iron
legion that look kind of like versions of ultron
robots i did a big video about superior iron man
a little while ago so i'll link it below in the
description but what it seems like is going on
with these ultron robots during the trailer like
they have the yellow eye so people have asked lots
of questions about the infinity stones because
obviously all these versions of the illuminati
characters are from alternate realities so things
would have gone down differently in the universes
that they came from if this alternate version
of the iron legion that looks more like ultron
tech comes from a universe where the infinity
stones are still whole they haven't been dusted
by their version of thanos it would actually be
really cool there a lot of you that also asked me
jocasta questions when talking about these ultron
robots if you're not a big comic book reader
jocasta is just another ai that iron man winds up
using there was an easter egg for her when iron
man was creating his new ai to use with his suit
and wound up using friday instead of the others
good evening boss one of them was joe costa
she's like another female ai that's a derivative
of ultron during the big ultron storyline in
the comics as far as we know nobody in the
mcu movies up to marvel phase 4 has used her as a
character so far and it just sounds like they're
using doctor strange too to try out all these
really weird deep cuts from the comics that they
haven't tried yet using these alternate versions
of characters this variant of scarlet wish looks
like she's walking into this chamber of the
illuminati's building crushing this ultron head
you see all the oil spilling out of it so that
explains how the movie's still pg-13 but it looks
like she's covered in blood because i think the
whole idea is that they're using them in the movie
as a sort of cannon fodder for her and the blood
all over her is actually just oil from them if you
ever wonder why there are so many cg characters in
movies like this it's because of situations like
this like they want to show a version of scarlet
witch just completely going crazy with their chaos
matches to show you how really powerful she could
possibly get and have her kill a bunch of really
big really powerful characters but if you saw her
popping a bunch of real people's heads and you saw
blood all over the place the movie would be rated
r so they have to have her do that to a bunch of
cg characters which is where the iron legion comes
in it looks like she's using her chaos magic to go
full supernova just completely destroying this
base so we'll see if any of these multiverse
illuminati wind up escaping this situation but
that's one of the reasons why i think they're
using so many of these as variants like professor
x patrick stewart isn't the original one from the
x-men movies obviously whichever version of iron
man created this version of the iron legion ultron
robots is not going to be the one from the mcu
played by robert downey jr that was actually
one of the reasons why they cremated his body
i think just so that fans wouldn't be like oh
yo his body's still there somebody could revive
him but because it is comic books we're talking
about there still are really crazy ways to explain
how people could bring iron man back in the mcu
like downloading a version of his consciousness
but obviously they're just gonna wait a long time
before they do anything with mcu iron man one of
the other beauties of doing variants of characters
is that you can do darker crazier versions that
you would never consider doing with your regular
characters that's really where sinister strange
comes in and then this marvel zombies version
of defender strange like they don't want to
completely throw mcu doctor strange under the bus
so they're doing it with a lot of these variants
same thing with mcu scarlet witch as crazy as she
gets during the movie it's gonna be some of these
other versions of characters that go way crazier
but if you zoom and enhance inside this illuminati
chamber here whatever's going on in this trailer
it just seems like they polish the special effects
it's just a little bit sharper if you zoom in
hands on the character to the left of him here
sitting down now it seems like this is a version
of reed richards from the original fantastic
four movies because notice how the bright part
of his costume is just localized to this circular
part on the right this looks very much like where
the fantastic four symbol from those versions of
the costumes were i love these costumes they're
missing something though right it's like spicy not
costumes and if you look at the size and shape of
his arms his shoulders relative to the rest of his
body it looks kind of like he skipped arm day at
the gym maybe because it's reed richards he is
a bit of a bookworm and his special powers just
make him look like that previously i thought that
it could be a black panther variant because the
brightness was just a little bit more blurred
and it looked like it covered his entire neck
and that's what a variant of black panther would
look like the necklace that he wears around his
neck would be a little bit different depending
on the variant but it would cover his entire neck
nonetheless and this one looks like it just covers
one part of his chest because we're talking about
multiverse counsel of really powerful characters
coming together like the illuminati during this
and they do call them the illuminati and the promo
materials a lot of you now also asking about the
council of reeds in the council of kangs now the
council of kangs they actually did mention in
the mcu so they are canon they share technology
and knowledge using the best of their universes
to improve the others during the loki's series
when he who remains was explaining the origin
of his own timeline and how he learned about the
multiverse and started working with other versions
of himself from other universes that was basically
him talking about a version of the council of
kangs from the comics it's the same basic idea as
the council of reeves just a whole bunch of kangs
not every version but a bunch of versions coming
together to work together i do rick and morty
videos for all the episodes on rick and morty the
council of ricks is also based on the council of
reads it's meant to be a big reference to that we
built a wall around infinity we separated all the
infinite universes from all the infinite universes
where he's the smartest man in the universe the
big difference between the council of kangs and
the council of reeds though even though they do
kind of the same thing is that kang the conqueror
is inherently viewed as a much darker character
so his version of the multiverse council just
devolves into war and fighting and that's where
you get to the multiverse kang wars that
they talked about during the loki series
even if the council of reeds had a disagreement
about something and some of the versions would be
darker than others you wouldn't expect the council
of reeds to devolve into a giant multiverse war
with each of them trying to erase each other's
universes the other thing about this trailer is
they're trying to be very misleading about it
too because you have baron mordo's voiceover
on the trailer saying the greatest threat
to our reality is you and what they do is
they intercut that voice over with the switch
between all the different versions and make you
think that the villain of the movie is all the
variants and technically that's true but some of
the versions are more evil more villainous than
the others and really at the end of the day the
whole movie is about rmcu scarlet witch trying to
find a version of billy and tommy so even though
it seems like this alternate version of scarlet
witch tries to kill mcu doctor strange in this
entire council of multiverse variants it's still
really mcu scarlet witch that's trying to push
this in a very particular direction so technically
i would view her as one of the main antagonists
it's like captain america civil war like even
though you understand where all the different
sides come from some characters seem worse than
others like baron zemo dancing zemo really the
villain of that situation we'll see who ultimately
winds up feeling like the dancing zemo at the end
of doctor strange 2 multiverse of badness or is
it gonna be like a Wandavision situation where
they say that grief is the technical main villain
or is it going to be a huge cosmic villain like
nightmare like a villain you could actually reach
out and punch if you tried there's also a couple
brand new scenes of defender strange during this
too not just marvel zombies version of defender
strange like after he turns into a zombie but
before he turns into a zombie so in this one
scene you see doctor strange visiting a bunch of
other realities it seems like he visits defender
strange's reality where everything is lush and
green like it's a very idealized version of rmcu
universe you see that they've changed the trailer
just a little bit because this is an old shot but
they've changed what his magic looks like it looks
white now like the white magic of the avatars and
the gods that we saw on moon knight and the look
that he's giving america chavez seems like a last
ditch kind of look like get out of here as fast as
you can there's no saving this situation and he's
trying to hold back this chaos magic creature
that does look like it winds up getting her
i'm guessing that he winds up failing and whatever
happens is what turns him into that marvel zombie
like why his body gets perverted and he goes full
evil i'm guessing one of the reasons why they're
using the white magic is just so that you can
tell them apart on screen a little bit better
and to show you how he's so much more powerful
than mcu doctor strange is right now so that
when he turns into a marvel zombie and goes
full evil he feels like even more of a threat
best example of that is the what if episode with
doctor strange doctor strange supreme completely
borking his entire universe because he was trying
to override a fixed point in time which is kind of
like their version of a nexus point but everyone
post all your theories in the comments below if
you have any questions about these other members
of this multiverse illuminati team just post them
in the comments below too hopefully we'll get
some more clues about some of the other members
of the team we have a pretty good idea who's on
the team but there's still a couple questions
i'll name a giveaway winner the next time i post a
big marvel video i'm also working on a moon knight
king the conqueror video that should post in the
next few days too everyone click here for my moon
knight episode 4 trailer video and click here for
my full moon knight episode 3 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!